Professor Charles
Bailyn: I've been talking
about general relativity,
and in particular,
the post-Newtonian,
relativistic effects.
These are the first things that
happen as the gravitational
field becomes strong enough that
Newton's laws don't perfectly
apply.
And let me just summarize
those, because we're going to
see them all in action in just a
minute.
So, here are the post-Newtonian
effects of general relativity.
And the first of them is the
precession of the perihelion.
I'm just going to list these.
And this was seen in the
nineteenth century already,
and correctly interpreted by
Einstein.
It had to do with Mercury's
orbit.
I should say,
this word, perihelion,
that means closest approach to
the Sun.
And so, that only applies for
planets if you have the
same--you can have the same kind
of effect in binary stars or in
other things,
in which case,
you might--they call it a
periastron.
That's the closest approach to
a star that isn't the Sun.
Or, here's a favorite word of
mine: perigalacticon,
I like that one.
That's the closest approach to
a galaxy.
You can have--the other side of
the orbit that is 180 degrees
away from the perigalacticon,
that's called the
anti-perigalacticon.
And you are challenged to use
that in a sentence at any time
over break.
Anyone who successfully does
that, send me an email
recounting the circumstances,
and I'll give you an extra
point or something.
All right, so,
precession of the perihelion,
that's one post-Newtonian
effect.
Another post-Newtonian effect
is the deflection of light by
mass, just because mass curves
space-time, and so,
light will follow a curved path
also.
This was first demonstrated in
1919 by the famous eclipse
observations of Eddington.
And it also has been manifested
recently in the discovery of
so-called gravitational lenses,
of various kinds,
in which the appearance of an
object is distorted by the fact
that the light from that object
has to pass by some other mass
on its way to your eye.
And so, I have a couple
examples, here,
which I'd like to show you of
gravitational lenses.
This is the famous Einstein
cross, so-called.
And what this is,
this is just a picture,
I think, from the Hubble Space
Telescope.
And these four objects,
here, are the same object.
That's a quasar.
It's just, for this purpose,
a point of light in the sky.
But it's located--its true
location is behind this thing.
This is much closer to you than
any of these guys.
This is a galaxy about partway
between us and the quasar.
And what has happened is,
if there were no deflection of
light, you'd see this quasar,
kind of, right behind the
galaxy.
And in fact,
it would be hard to distinguish
between the two.
But what has happened is,
because there's this galaxy in
the way, the light from the
quasar starts coming this way
and then bends around the galaxy
and comes back toward us.
And the same is true up here
and down here,
and down here.
And so, you get four different
images of this quasar--of the
same quasar.
And they know it's the same
quasar, because they've taken
spectra of the thing,
and it's the exact same
spectrum on all four of these
things.
And so, these are just four
different images of the same
object.
And the reason they're not
symmetrically distributed,
here, is because the mass in
this galaxy is not symmetrically
distributed.
And so, depending on what path
you take, you get different
amounts of deflections.
So, that's a classic example of
gravitational lens.
Yes?
Student: Why can't we
also see this quasar in the
middle?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: In principle,
you could see it,
right through here,
but there are two things about
the path that comes right at us.
There are two problems with
that.
One is that for various--these
guys are all magnified,
and the one that comes through
the middle is demagnified.
Second of all,
it's right in back of the
galaxy.
But, in principle,
there's a fifth one down in the
middle, that's true.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Sorry?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Okay,
so what--let me,
let me pause,
here, and tell you what a
quasar is.
A quasar is a quasi-stellar
object.
What it is, is,
it's a very bright source right
in the middle of a galaxy.
And so, it's actually a point
source of light.
It looks like a star.
These things turns out to
be--what they really are,
it turns out,
are massive black holes in the
center of galaxies,
accreting material from the
galaxy itself.
But they appear to be very
bright nuclei of galaxies and if
you could look really hard,
you could see the galaxy--the
background galaxy around this
thing.
But in this particular case,
it's way too faint to see.
The galaxy has a much larger
extent, because it's all the
stars and all the stuff in the
galaxies.
It's not coming right from the
middle.
And this one's much closer than
those, and so,
you can actually see that it's
extended, in this case.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Oh,
it's not the black hole that's
emitting the light.
It's the material falling into
the black hole that gets heated
up.
I'll actually talk about this
on Thursday a little bit.
Other questions about the
Einstein cross,
here?
Let me show you another one.
So, this is a Hubble Space
Telescope picture of a cluster
of galaxies.
See all these different things,
all these extended sources,
those are all individual
galaxies.
Galaxies, it turns out,
come in clusters.
And so, here is a big bunch of
galaxies.
And some of the galaxies you
see here--most of the galaxies,
all these big ones,
are part of this cluster.
This is a cluster that's
relatively nearby to Earth.
But some of the galaxies are
actually not in the cluster.
They're much, much further away.
They're in back of the cluster.
And these things--these,
sort of, streaky things you see
all over the place here--what
these are,
are galaxies that are in back
of the cluster of galaxies,
whose light has been lensed
when it passes through the
cluster of galaxies.
And it's been stretched.
It's because,
what happened is,
this thing here,
for example,
ought to be a tiny little
galaxy that you can barely see
here,
except the light from the top
end of that galaxy got bent up
to here.
And the light from the bottom
end of that galaxy got bent down
to here.
And that's why they're all sort
of in this kind of--all these
things are kind of circular
around the center of this thing,
because this is a very,
very massive galaxy.
And that's the thing that's
doing the lensing.
And so, it effectively distorts
the shape of the background
galaxy.
And you can see a couple more
of them around this massive
galaxy, here.
These are pretty,
but they also can be used in
order to understand the
distribution of mass inside the
galaxy cluster.
Because the particular way in
which these galaxies are
distorted depends on how much
mass there is in this galaxy
cluster,
and how that mass is
distributed.
And so, these are used to study
the mass distributions of galaxy
clusters.
And so, this is a different
kind of gravitational lensing.
And finally,
let me show you a joke.
This is a picture of The
Smithsonian Institute in
Washington, D.C.,
where there are a group--well,
actually, The Smithsonian
Astrophysical Observatory is
actually in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
And there, there are a group of
people who study gravitational
lensing.
And they have taken this
picture.
And imagine what it would look
like if, about halfway between
where you're looking and this
building, there were a black
hole the mass of Saturn.
And here's what it looks like.
And all these distortions are
simply due to the change in
direction caused by the
gravitational force of this
imaginary black hole.
And so, you could see what
happens.
The black hole is,
sort of, right down the middle,
here.
And so, off at the edges,
there's only a little bit of
distortion.
And then, in the middle,
everything goes haywire.
Let me take this back a notch.
Take a look at these two
central towers,
this one, here,
and that one.
And so, they're kind of--what's
happened, here,
is that you're seeing light
that has gone out and then been
bent back towards you,
so, it looks like the tower's
over here.
But look, that same tower is
down here.
And so, that's light from the
tower that went down and
underneath the black hole and
then got pulled back up to reach
your eye.
So, there are two paths from
that tower to your eye,
and you can see both of them.
Look at this thing here.
What's that?
Let me go back to the original
picture.
That's this statue.
And what's happened is,
light from the top of the
statue has gone up and over the
black hole, and come down
towards you.
Whoops--and so, here it is.
And similarly,
the clouds that were up here
have been bent down--have gone
underneath the black hole and
been bent back up,
so you can see them here.
And so, they worked out all the
distortions of this,
and so, they like to show this
kind of amusing picture.
They actually had a movie,
which I couldn't find on the
Net, last night,
which is too bad,
where they take the black hole,
and they kind of move it across
the front of this thing.
You can see all the distortions
coming out.
And so, you can have enormous
fun with this kind of thing.
Needless to say,
this is not--this particular
picture has not ever actually
been observed.
That's calculated,
not actually observed.
But, you can see the kinds of
bizarre effects that
gravitational lensing can
create.
And, as I mentioned,
in some cases,
these are scientifically useful
things, because you can
determine the distribution of
the mass that's causing the
lensing.
Questions? Yes?
Student: So in that
particular case it's always
[Inaudible]
that all the light from the
other side get lensed?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Well,
what you have to do--it depends
a little bit on the exact mass
distribution of the lens.
In this case,
I think they're assuming a
point source.
And so, it is,
in general, true that if
there's a gravitational lens,
you end up seeing more light
than you otherwise would,
because it's focused in towards
you.
So, the total amount of light
that you see,
if you're seeing a lensed
object,
is typically larger than the
amount you would see in the
absence of the lens.
So, there are more paths of
light that are curved towards
you than are curved away from
you.
If you're standing over on the
side, you'll lose a little bit
of the light,
because it will be curved in
some other direction.
And so, there are more
different way--you can see the
thing--you know,
it's kind of an early twentieth
century art thing.
You can see the same object
from two different sides at
once, and you get these curious
distortions.
Yes?
Student: If you're
looking into a galaxy cluster
and there are a lot of streaks
and a lot of galaxies and you
don't know the mass of the
galaxy to try to find the mass
[Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yeah.
Student: How do you know
what streaks belong to which
galaxies?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: What streaks belong
to which galaxies?
Okay.
You know that the streaks must
come from galaxies that are
located behind the galaxy
cluster, that are not themselves
part of the galaxy cluster.
And, in order to understand
what that streak is,
in principle,
you'd need to know the exact
shape and size of that galaxy.
You can go and take a spectrum
of the thing and figure out how
far away it is and what the
relative distances are.
But, in principle,
you would need to know the
exact shape of that galaxy
before it was distorted,
which you don't know.
And so, what you have to do,
to interpret these things,
is to take many streaks and
assume that the galaxies that
caused them are kind of
normal--a normal distribution of
galaxy shapes.
And so, it's more of a
statistical process than using
them one at a time,
in that case.
The quasars are a little easier
to deal with,
because you know that they're
points.
And this--and there are various
kinds of limits to how much
information you can get out of
this.
And it's quite tricky to do.
What's easy to do is the thing
that they did in that picture.
You imagine that there is a
mass in the way,
and you figure out what happens
to the light from the
background.
What's hard to do is to observe
the light in the background,
not know what it ought to look
like, really,
and infer what the mass
distribution is.
That's a harder problem.
And there's a lot of
theoretical effort,
at the moment,
going into trying to solve that
problem of,
here's what you see,
infer what the mass
distribution has to be in order
for you to see that.
Yes?
Student: Have we ever
observed where it was the
perfect lensing when you have a
ring around [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yes,
there are some Einstein rings.
I don't have them here.
Hubble Space Telescope has
observed a bunch of these
things.
Typically, they're not full
rings, because the mass
distribution is not perfectly
symmetric.
But there are,
as you can see,
you can see,
those were short,
kind of, little arcs.
And if you get it set up just
the right way,
the arcs can go a large
fraction of the way around the
circle.
So, these are,
kind of, fun things to observe,
and also give you useful
information.
So, that's the second of the
post-Newtonian effects.
The first was the precession of
the perihelion.
Now, the deflection of light.
Moving on, number three,
here, is what we talked about
last time, which is the
gravitational redshift.
And here, we have delta lambda
over lambda [Δ λ/ λ],
or alternatively,
in the case of the problem set
you're working on,
the pulse period,
in either case--these are
usually given the letter
Z, that's redshift.
That's a definition of this
quantity, Z,
which is often used.
And this is equal to this
quantity.
And this is the Schwarzschild
radius of some mass.
And this R is the
distance of the light source
from that mass.
And what this equation
signifies is how much redshift
is there, if you observe this
thing when you are sitting at
infinity--do you observe from
infinite distance.
And what do I mean by infinite
distance?
What I mean is that
R_S / R
goes to zero.
That's what infinite R
means, in this case.
So, you're sitting out there a
long, long, long way away from
any gravitational effect.
You're looking at a light that
is emitted inside a
gravitational field,
relatively close to some mass.
That light is redshifted by
this amount.
And pulse periods are also
lengthened by the same amount,
and I'll come back to that in a
minute.
One thing I want to say right
now is, what happens if you are
an observer and you're not
infinitely far away?
What happens if you're just a
little bit further away than the
light source is,
or perhaps even if you're
closer to the object than the
light source is?
And, in that case,
if the observer is not at
infinity, then the observed
redshift is equal to the
redshift from the source to
infinity,
which you could calculate by
this formula,
minus the redshift from the
observer to infinity,
which you can also calculate
with that same formula.
So, you have to subtract two
things.
Basically, what happens is,
imagine the light going
from--it starts out at the
source,
it goes to the observer,
and then it keeps going all the
way out to infinity.
And you want to ask,
what does the observer see?
The observer sees that portion
of the redshift that happens
between the source and the
observer.
So, to figure out what that is,
you figure out the redshift
from the source to infinity.
You figure out the redshift
from the observer to infinity.
And you subtract those things.
And that gives you the redshift
from the source to the observer.
Okay, yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: No,
no, no, but look what happens.
When R_S / R
is equal to zero that means
there is no redshift.
That means there is no redshift.
It doesn't mean that the
observed wavelength is zero.
It means the change in the
wavelength is zero.
Yeah, that's important.
And, just to comment on the
problem set here,
the idea on the second problem
of the problem set is,
you do have an observer at
infinity.
So, here's the observer.
Here's some neutron star.
And you have a light source
that can either be on the
surface of the neutron star,
or it can be raised off the
surface of the neutron star.
And basically,
what you're observing is the
change in the light source.
So, this has some redshift,
some pretty large redshift,
because it's sitting on the
surface of a neutron star.
This, because it's further away
from the neutron star,
has slightly less redshift.
And what you are interested in
is the change in the redshift.
And the idea behind the problem
is, you want to set this up so
that that change in the redshift
is the same as the change in the
redshift due to the Doppler
shift,
if this whole thing was in
orbit around something.
That's the plan of that
particular problem.
Okay, so that's the third of
the post-Newtonian relativistic
effects, and there's a fourth
one.
The fourth is gravitational
waves, which I may have time to
come back and talk about in
detail.
At the moment,
though, I just want to say what
the effect of these things is,
rather than talk in detail
about what they are.
The effect is that the orbital
period decreases.
Now, it turns out,
this is a relatively small
effect, and it is not observed
in the Solar System,
even in Mercury,
which has the strongest
relativistic effect.
Okay.
So, those are four
post-Newtonian effects of
general relativity.
And what I want to talk about
now is what has become probably
the best laboratory for general
relativity that we know of.
The problem with general
relativity is you can't actually
study it all that much in the
lab,
because, in order to study it,
you need strong gravitational
forces.
And it's very difficult to
create strong gravitational
forces in a laboratory.
What would you need to do?
You'd need to take some massive
object, crush it down to the
size of a black hole or
something, and have it sit there
in your lab.
And this is not something that
one can do.
And so, you have to go and look
at astronomical objects in order
to find suitable situation in
which to study these
relativistic effects.
So, the best lab for general
relativity--lab for G.R.,
here, is a set of objects.
And one object in particular,
which is referred to as the
Binary Pulsar.
This is discussed in the
readings for this week's problem
set.
The discovery of this
particular object led to a Nobel
Prize for its discoverers,
and that's what's discussed in
that article.
So, the first thing to talk
about, here, is what is a
pulsar?
So, pulsars were discovered in
the late 1960s by a woman named
Jocelyn Bell.
And she wired up a whole field
in Cambridge,
England, to make it behave like
a radio telescope,
and discovered that there were
objects in the sky,
celestial objects,
that seemed to be emitting
pulses of radio waves.
So, the observed signature of
these things--what was observed
is pulses of radio waves.
So, you get kind of a blip
every few seconds.
It goes blip,
blip, blip, blip,
and so forth.
And these pulses come by--so,
the pulsations happen
once--it's sort of with a period
of somewhere between
milliseconds and ten seconds.
So, they come at you pretty
rapidly.
Most of them are a few seconds
or maybe a fraction of a second.
So, these things are blipping
away.
And they had no idea what these
were.
And the first four of them they
gave the nickname LGM1,
LGM2,
LGM3,
LGM4,
for "little green men," because
the thought was that these might
actually--they thought,
briefly, that these might be
signals from some
extraterrestrial intelligence,
because, you know,
it's a very regular signal.
It's hard to imagine how those
could have been created.
But, fortunately,
before they published their
paper, somebody suggested a
better solution,
which turns out to be correct.
That what these things are,
are rotating magnetized neutron
stars.
And this was the first direct
evidence that neutron stars
existed.
And the reason they thought
they were neutron stars is
because the speed with which
these things pulsed is supposed
to be reflected in the rotation
of these neutron stars.
And something that rotates ten
times a second had better be
pretty small.
And so, there was strong size
limits on the neutron stars.
It's not going to matter,
too much, exactly what these
things are, but I'm going to
explain it to you anyway.
But don't worry too much about
it.
For the purposes of relativity,
the key point,
here, is that it's an extremely
accurate clock--that you get
these blips coming out of the
thing,
and that creates a very
accurate clock.
And then, you can see very
small changes in the pulse rate
of these things.
So, now let me just briefly
tell you what these are.
Oh, I should mention--so,
the discovery of neutron stars,
this was a very big deal.
This was the first strongly
relativistic object that had
ever been discovered and they
awarded a Nobel Prize to Jocelyn
Bell's thesis supervisor.
And there is some feeling among
some folks that this was an
injustice.
And so, there is--people
discuss the story of Jocelyn
Bell and the discovery of
pulsars.
To her credit,
Bell has never complained.
Bell and the discovery of
pulsar-- Student: Did the
thesis advisor do anything?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Oh yes,
well that's actually an
interesting question.
The question is,
"Did the thesis advisor do
anything?"
As a thesis advisor myself,
I take that question seriously.
Well, this is the whole debate
about who should have gotten the
Nobel Prize.
The thesis supervisor thought
up the experiment,
and Bell did it.
So, who ought to get the credit
for that?
It's actually a subtle
question, and it bears on
problem four,
or whatever it is,
of this week's homework,
so it's worth thinking about.
Jocelyn Bell and the discovery
of pulsars--he also got the
money.
That's not trivial sometimes.
And the moral of the story--it
depends on who you ask,
for exactly the reason that you
bring up.
One moral of the story is that
grad students,
particularly female grad
students, never get any credit
and that this is a great
injustice.
As you get older,
your attitude towards this
problem changes.
And the alternative moral is
that thinking and doing are not
the same, and that thinking is
better than doing.
Now, one could raise various
objections, and people have,
to this line of thought.
And interestingly enough,
the next time they had to give
a Nobel Prize for something to
do with pulsars,
which was the discovery of the
Binary Pulsar,
they did give the prize also to
the graduate student.
And it's the graduate student's
description of what he did that
you're actually reading for this
problem set.
So, you can opine on this topic
yourselves on the problem set.
Anyway, a matter of continuing
controversy in scientific
circles.
But let me just briefly show
you what's supposed to be
happening, here.
Here is a neutron star--very
dense thing, yeah?
And it's rotating,
so, it's got some axis of
rotation, here--a different
color.
So, here's its axis of rotation.
And it's rotating around its
axis.
And it's also got a magnetic
field.
But the magnetic field,
the pole of the magnetic field,
is not the same as the rotation
pole.
That's true on the Earth as
well.
Magnetic north is not exactly
in the same place as true North,
the center of the Earth's
rotation.
And if you're in northern
Canada and you try and follow a
compass signal north,
you're going to get yourself
into big trouble.
Because, you know,
the actual magnetic pole is
somewhere in northern Canada,
and if you're north of that,
you'll be going south when you
think you're going north.
Anyway, imagine that here's the
magnetic field.
Magnetic fields have these sort
of field lines that look like
this.
And what happens in these
things is that there's radio
emission coming out of the
magnetic poles.
So, there's radio emission
coming out this way.
And so, if you're observing
this from here,
say, you see radio emission
when the pole is pointing
towards you.
But then, if the thing is
rotating, then half a rotation
later--so, later,
but not too much later,
because this thing rotates
really quickly.
Here's the neutron star,
still, and now the pole's over
here, because it's rotated
around by a factor of two,
by half a rotation.
So, now the radio emission's
coming this way.
And if you're still sitting
observing the thing down here,
you don't see anything.
So this is on, and this is off.
So, you watch this pole.
It's sort of like a lighthouse,
you know.
A lighthouse has a beam of
light.
And when it's pointing towards
you, you see light.
And then, as it's going around
in a circle, you don't see
light.
Then it points towards you--you
see light again.
And so, the consequence of this
is that you get something that
looks--if you plot radio
emission versus time,
you get these very regularly
spaced blips.
And it is the time between one
blip and the next that's the
pulse period.
And so, for our purposes
here--I mean,
pulsars are very interesting
objects, but we're not going to
go into them in any depth.
As objects, the key thing is
that it's got this really
accurate clock on it.
And if you imagine a pulsar in
orbit around something,
when it comes towards you,
each one of these blips happens
a little closer to you.
So, the light travel time from
the blip to you is less.
And so, it seems like the blips
happen closer together,
because each one of them has
emitted a little closer towards
you.
Similarly, when it's going
away, each blip is emitted a
little further away.
It takes extra time to get to
you, and the pulse period,
the length of time between the
pulses, appears to be longer.
By how much?
By exactly the amount that the
Doppler shift formula would
suggest.
And so, the pulse period obeys
the same rules in terms of its
length as wavelengths of light
do.
Okay.
So, for example,
it is true that Δ pulse period
over pulse period is equal to
the usual Doppler shift formula,
which is approximately equal to
V_R / c,
in the Newtonian approximation.
Oh, and I should say,
in problem one on the problem
set, you can use the Newtonian
approximation,
because, as you'll discover,
the velocity of the object as
it goes around in its orbit is
significantly less than the
speed of light.
Okay.
So, they discover this Binary
Pulsar with a short orbital
period.
The orbital period--this is now
the orbital period--is around
eight hours, which is pretty
short, but it's still not very
relativistic.
But you can measure these
things to incredible accuracy.
So, you cannot only see the
velocity curve that we're used
to.
You can also see tiny
deviations from the Newtonian
velocity curve.
And from those tiny deviations
from the Newtonian velocity
curve, you can see these
post-Newtonian effects.
In particular,
it turns out--so this in an
elliptical orbit.
It's not a circular orbit.
It's a highly elliptical orbit.
And you can see the precession
of the periastron as the
ellipticity--as the direction of
the orbit,
as the position of the orbit,
changes, you can see the
precession of the periastron.
And the precession of the
periastron happens at the rate
of four degrees per year.
Now, compare that to Mercury,
in which the same effect can be
observed at 43 arc seconds per
century.
So, this is a much stronger
effect.
Okay.
You can also see the
gravitational redshift.
Now, let me show you how this
comes about.
But you have to be careful
about exactly what you're
seeing.
You're not seeing the
gravitational redshift,
due to the fact that the clock
is sitting on a neutron star.
Because, okay,
you're seeing the effect of the
companion object of this other
object in the system,
which happens to be also a
neutron star,
but not a pulsar.
And what happens is this.
Here's your clock,
and it's going around in some
kind of elliptical orbit.
Here's the center of mass.
Here's the other;
so, there's a clock that's
going around like this.
And then, there's some other
object that's going around like
this.
They're approximately the same
mass.
And so, sometimes these objects
are close to each other.
For example,
here--when they're here and
here, this is--call this
position 1.
And then, later on,
half an orbit later,
they're out here in position 2,
and this one's gone all the way
out to here.
So, at position 1,
the objects are close,
and so, the clock is redshifted
by the presence of the other
object.
And so, it has to--there's a
redshift due to the other
object, which is nearby.
Objects are close,
so, the redshift caused by the
other object is large.
At position 2 the distance to
the other object is much
greater--distance is greater.
And so, redshift is less.
Now, it's also true that
there's a redshift caused by the
fact that this clock is sitting
on neutron star.
But the thing about that
redshift is it doesn't change
during the course of the orbit.
So, you can't actually tell
that it's there.
Because that's one of the
differences between measuring
pulse periods of pulsars and
measuring wavelengths of light.
With these spectral features in
light, you know what it's
supposed to be if it isn't
redshifted.
In the case of the pulsars you
don't know, in advance,
what the pulse period ought to
be.
So, you can't tell what it
should be if there was no
gravitational field or was no
Doppler shift.
All that you can tell is the
amount by which it changes
during the course of an orbital
period.
And so, you're comparing the
redshift when the objects are in
this position to the redshift of
the objects in this position.
The redshift caused by the
pulsar itself doesn't change,
but the redshift caused by
where its companion is,
and the gravitational force
exerted by the companion,
does change.
The consequence,
by the way, is that if these
things are in a circular orbit,
you can't see the gravitational
redshift, because they're always
the same distance away from each
other,
and the gravitational redshift
doesn't change.
There is a gravitational
redshift, but it doesn't change
during the course of the period,
and it's the change that you
can observe.
Yes?
Student: So,
in this case,
redshift refers not to the
frequency of,
like, the light in the pulses?
It refers to the [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: It's the time
between pulses.
Yeah.
You could imagine that the
pulses might have a spectral
feature and then you would see
it in the spectral feature,
too.
In fact, that's extremely hard
to have that.
That doesn't happen.
It's a continuum of light.
So it's the time--what you
observe is the time between
pulses.
And that can be observed
extremely accurately.
You get 20 decimal places of
accuracy.
It's really kind of frightening.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Well,
if it's a circular orbit,
no.
If there's a circular orbit,
they're always the same
distance around each other.
They're chasing each other
around in a circle.
That's what it means to be
circular orbit,
if every point on the orbit is
the same distance to the center
for both objects.
So, each object is the same
distance from the center of mass
at all times.
That's what makes it a circular
orbit.
And they're always on the
opposite side of the center of
mass, so, the distance between
them is always the same for a
circular orbit.
I'll draw it.
Here we go.
Here's the center of mass,
supposing these objects are the
same mass as each other.
Here's one of them,
it's going around this way and
here it is right now.
And here's the other object,
it's going around this way,
and here it is right now.
And they're just going to march
around this circle,
each being on the opposite side
of the center and the distance
between them won't change.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Oh,
they only overlap if the two
objects are the same mass.
So, if one object is more
massive than the other,
then you've got a little circle
going this way and a big circle
going this way.
Let's see, it would have to be
there.
And then, they're still the
same distance from each other at
every point along the way.
Because each one of them is
always the same distance from
the center of mass,
in the middle,
and they're always on opposite
sides.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: So,
the way ellipses work is--so,
here's an ellipse.
And the ellipse can be big or
little--here's an ellipse.
They're doing ellipses,
and the center of mass is at
one focus of the ellipse.
It's not at the center of the
ellipse.
That's the key thing.
And so, when you're furthest
away from the focus,
you have a long distance from
the center.
When you're closer,
you're closer.
And it's because,
each one of these things,
you don't maintain a constant
distance from the center of
mass.
Okay, so, because of this
effect in elliptical orbits,
in Binary Pulsars,
in elliptical orbits,
you can observe the
gravitational redshift.
Also – and this is what they
got the Nobel Prize for,
really – you can see that the
orbital period decreases.
It's getting shorter.
The two objects are spiraling
in together.
Decreases due to gravitational
waves.
So, you can observe three
different post-Newtonian effects
in these systems.
So, this constitutes a serious
test of general relativity in
the following way.
If you could do only Newtonian
measurements,
what would you get?
Well, we did this before,
for the planets.
What you can get out of a
Newtonian measurement of
velocity--remember,
what you're doing is you're
measuring the Doppler shift;
you're measuring radial
velocity.
What you get is,
you can determine
M_total,
the total mass of the system,
if you know the inclination.
That's something we tended to
leave out.
We always claim these things
are edge-on because it makes the
calculations easier.
But, in fact,
you get a different answer
depending on what the
inclination is,
and you don't necessarily know
the inclination.
So, if you now measure the
precession of the periastron,
then this also--the amount of
that also depends on
M_1,
M_2,
the two masses,
and the inclination.
So, you can solve for the
inclination now.
This isn't actually precisely
how you do it,
but conceptually,
this is how it works.
You now solve for the
inclination.
You then know
M_total,
but not each individual mass.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn:
M_1,
M_2 and the
inclination, this is i.
But you don't know the
individual masses.
Now, if both objects were
pulsars and you could see both
orbits, then you would also know
the individual masses.
But you don't.
You only see one of these
objects.
Okay.
So, now, the next effect is
gravitational redshift.
And this, again,
depends, in a different way,
on M_1,
M_2,
and the inclination.
And so, now you can solve for
M_1.
And since you know the total
mass, you also get
M_2.
So, at this point you know
M_1,
M_2 and the
inclination.
What's happening here is that
each time you measure an effect,
you get an additional
constraint.
And you started out having
three unknowns and one equation.
And, of course,
you can't solve for three
unknowns with only one equation.
But then, you observe two more
effects.
So, now, you have three
unknowns and three equations.
So, now, you can solve for all
of these things.
Now you know everything.
At this point you can predict
what the period change should
be, because you know everything.
Then you can measure that.
And so, you have a specific
prediction created from general
relativity.
You can measure this effect,
and the prediction turns out to
be correct, to within the
measurement errors.
And the measurement errors are
getting more precise all the
time, because as time goes on
the amount of change in the
period,
since they first observe it,
increases.
Because the period's changing
more, it's slowing down and the
period's getting faster and
faster, the objects are falling
in.
And so, over time that change
mounts up.
You can measure it better and
better and better as time goes
on.
And so, the precision of this
test of general relativity is
going up all the time.
So, it is now clear that
general relativity is correct,
to some number of decimal
places.
I'm going to put correct in
quotes, because it depends how
accurately you can measure it,
but the accuracy is going up
all the time--in the
post-Newtonian approximation.
Remember, all these effects are
post-Newtonian only.
Actually, they've now observed
a couple of post-post-Newtonian
effects, which are the next term
in the series expansion.
And those are also correct,
but they're not measured as
precisely yet.
So, it's clear that general
relativity is correct as long as
everything is still pretty close
to the Newtonian thing.
You can actually still have
orbits.
But you could imagine a theory
which is like Newton in the
first term of the expansion,
like general relativity in the
second term, the post-Newtonian
term, but different in very
strong gravitational fields.
So, you've got to get the first
term to work,
and it's got to come out like
Newton.
You've got to get the second
term to work.
It's got to come out like
general relativity.
But then, you can imagine all
sorts of different functions
that work with this,
work with this,
and are different in the higher
order terms.
And the higher order terms are
the things that give rise to all
these exciting effects,
like event horizons,
and things like that.
So, what would be nice--it
would be good to have some way
of testing strong field effects.
And by that,
I mean, situations in which the
Schwarzschild radius over
r becomes close to 1.
Because, in that case,
all the terms in this series
expansion, contribute.
And, if you can get it--if the
theory is right there,
then all the terms have to be
the same,
and you don't have this nagging
doubt about whether you could
come up with some theory that
looks like Newton,
in the same way that general
relativity looks like Newton,
but is different once you get
higher order terms.
Looks like general relativity
in the second term,
but turns out to be a totally
different theory.
Needless to say,
the theorists have come up
with, literally,
an infinite number of such
theories.
Because there's a whole
infinite family of things which
satisfy this,
and look different at the upper
level.
So, what we're going to talk
about next time is how one might
go about testing strong field
relativity.
This is a subject close to my
heart because it's what I do for
a living, and we'll talk about
it on Thursday.